so what is a medium fidelity prototype
and how does it differ from a paper
prototype like the one you've been
working with the main difference that is
relevant for us at the moment is the
idea of interactivity and clickability
when we worked with the paper prototype
we had to indicate to users what
happened when they clicked a given
button and we had to be able to guide
them when they were confused by our
layout for our next iteration we'll be
building a clickable interactive
prototype that means that we could hand
a user the prototype ask them to do a
task and then get out of the way when
they click on the screen the app will
move to the right place when they reach
their destination it should be clear
it's important to remember that this
doesn't mean that we have a beautiful or
well-designed prototype yet we don't
have animations we don't have perfect
line setup and we don't have a final
look for the app in fact for our medium
fidelity prototype it's possible to
simply take your paper prototype drawn
in marker on a piece of paper and import
it into a prototyping software the key
here is having primary navigation points
which enable you to get feedback on
whether a user can achieve your intended
task of the app